bon vous avez discussion entre le moment
où Cyril karunagaran envoie la première
demande de subvention et le jour où
j'apprends on va voir au-dessus vous
êtes parfaitement je dirais sur la même
posture ou explication que la ministre
c'est à dire que vous êtes
concerné par le projet mais vous
finalement vous tenez à distance pour
qu'il n'y ait je dirais pas de souci
je vous permets pas
je ne précise rien du tout vous allez
retirer tout de suite ce que vous voulez
dire aucune posture chez moi vous
entendez il y a aucune posture je ne
suis pas un homme politique déclaration
vous retirez tout de suite je n'ai rien
de comparable avec Madame c'est clair
rien de compliqué rien de la même
manière que j'ai fait observer hier à
Madame le Premier ministre sur la
question de l'équité et de la
transparence elle est utilisée les mêmes
mots que l'inspection générale de
l'administration pardonnez-moi
pour le coup n'interprétez pas non non
j'interprète des choses qui sont
totalement je suis dans aucune posture
monsieur je vous réponds sincérité et
avec honnêteté transparence et bien
arrêter de me lancer à la figure des
choses rien à la figure j'ai le droit de
formuler de reformuler comme j'ai fait
tout à l'heure pour être sûr d'avoir
bien compris donc vous venez de nous
donner des éléments vous avez été
conviés on va poursuivre à une réunion
avec notamment le directeur de cabinet
de Madame Schiappa et le secrétaire
général du cpdr le 22 avril 2021
pouvez-vous nous décrire le déroulement
de cette réunion et est-ce qu'à ce
moment-là le niveau
de la subvention a été évoquée
clairement un montant
non monsieur le rapporteur finalement
donc il y a une seconde
demande de combien de leur rappeler on a
déjà parlé de
355000 euros qui est adressé pouvez-vous
nous indiquer les raisons qui ont
conduit le seppm a déposé un deuxième
montant avec un montant donc rehaussée
de subventions même si j'ai entendu vous
nous avez vous nous avez dit à quelques
instants que le 300 000 vous ne vous en
aviez entendu parler pour le coup si
j'interprète
par les médias mais vous n'avez jamais
puisque la demande initiale était de 635
000 vous vous n'avez jamais eu
connaissance d'une proposition à 300 000
d'abord votre lecture est fausse parce
que je ne dirige pas un cabinet
fausse parce que Cyril karunagaran
administrativement il n'est pas sur mes
ordres c'est plutôt le contraire vous
avez une lecture fausse parce que vous
m'attribuez mais une sorte de non non
non je ne peux pas vous laisser dire ce
que vous avez dit
moi Monsieur le Directeur vous n'êtes
pas là pour maîtriser on est là pour
avoir monsieur échanges à poser et
surtout le rapporteur vous faites
vous faites un raccourci non je pose des
questions un raccourci je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas de vous ne
faites un raccourci malheureux je vous
le dis vous faites un raccourci
malheureux vous ne comparez à Madame
Chapat je n'ai absolument rien
absolument pas ce que j'ai mis sur le
fond ni sur la forme c'est clair c'est
mais d'abord vous n'avez pas de ni
d'ordre ni je vous demande d'aller
excusez-moi je pense que vous devez
garder et vos nerfs et votre maîtrise
nous essayons de le faire et poursuivons
et je vous le dis je suis quelqu'un vous
savez je suis quelqu'un d'assez entier
je respecte les institutions et je
respecte les gens qui me respectent mais
j'ai le moment où on me respecte plus je
vais aller sur un autre temps je vous le
dis tout de suite
mais je préfère mais je n'ai jamais
changé de trajectoire et vous pourrez
regarder au long des auditions j'essaie
d'ailleurs d'être assez constant
certains disent même que c'est bien ils
apprécient cette forme de sérénité voilà
je vous dis
alors regardons la sérénité c'est pour
c'est pour l'honneur de l'institution
que vous représentez et pour l'intérieur
de tout le monde c'est pour l'honneur de
la situation et au-dessus de vous donc
c'est pour l'honneur s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît vous aussi s'il vous
plaît il n'y a pas d'accusation à porter
vous le redis voilà revenons peut-être
parmé revenons sur cette réunion du 22
avril il y a eu une réunion le 22 avril
et la question est-ce que vous y étiez
bien cette réunion le 22 avril ce n'est
pas une réunion le 22 Avril c'est une
invitation que je reçois pour
être reçu par Madame Marlène Schiappa
ce que je vous ai dit ce que vous avez
dit c'est à dire qu'après elle n'a pas
pu initialement elle a été retenue par
un engagement auprès du président de la
République ou le Premier ministre je
m'appelle plus honnêtement en tout cas
pas d'un événement important
et par conséquent le cabinet m'a fait
savoir que je serai reçu par le
directeur de cabinet et pendant une
heure nous avons discuté avec le
directeur du cabinet du projet encore
une fois ce que vous a dit le directeur
de cabinet est vrai à aucun moment il
n'y a eu d'engagement financier ni de sa
part ni de la part de la ministre ni de
la part du cabinet d'accord
nous avons encore une fois affiner le
projet et il voulait se tenir au courant
pour le compte de la ministre des
détails des détails qui que que
recevait qui a pris ensuite la décision
donc de modifier le
montant du dépôt du dossier donc d'avoir
un deuxième dossier déposé à hauteur de
355000 euros monsieur karunagaran
quand je vous dis c'est pas pour me
dérober encore une fois je
défais d'accord donnez moi juste une
réponse je vous non non mais c'est ce
que je suis en train de faire en étant
le plus détaillé même si ça vous embête
parce que je pense que le l'heure du
déjeuner est proche etc et vous avez
beaucoup
on va prendre si vous voulez bien le
temps qu'il faut pour que vous puissiez
comprendre OK et on va parler calmement
ne me venez pas me piquer au vif et je
demandais de garder mes nerfs je ne
viens donc je ne kiffe personne au vif
encore une fois
dès le moment où on rentre dans une
traduction administrative et financière
d'un projet que j'ai porté
intellectuellement je remets l'ensemble
des éléments que nous avions préparés
ensemble avec Cyril caronagarran à Cyril
car onagara qui va se charger de la
traduction administrative
administrative de ce projet
[Musique]